un parto por cesárea generalmente
conocido como cesárea es un
procedimiento quirúrgico en que se
realizan incisiones en el abdomen y
útero de una mujer para dar a luz un
bebé
algunas cesáreas se planifican sin
embargo a menudo la necesidad del
procedimiento se torna evidente después
del inicio del trabajo de parto cuando
las condiciones anormales hacen que un
parto natural no sea seguro para la
madre o su bebé
las indicaciones comunes para el parto
por cesárea incluyen d'història placenta
previa y sufrimiento fetal la distancia
o trabajo de parto no progresivo
prolongado puede producirse cuando la
cabeza del bebé no cabe por el canal del
parto o su cuerpo se encuentra en una
posición desfavorable como por ejemplo
cuando está perpendicular al canal del
parto o de nalgas como lo es la posición
de nalgas la placenta previa se presenta
cuando la placenta se encuentra en una
posición baja y obstruye de manera
parcial o por completo la abertura
cervical el sufrimiento fetal se produce
cuando la salud del bebé se encuentra en
peligro inminente por lo general debido
al flujo insuficiente de sangre a través
de la placenta o el cordón umbilical el
sufrimiento fetal puede producirse
cuando la placenta se separa de la pared
del útero antes del parto o el cordón
umbilical se comprime o estrangula
y otras afecciones que pueden requerir
un parto por cesárea incluyen
nacimientos múltiples tumores grandes
del útero herpes genital u otras
infecciones o problemas médicos tales
como la hipertensión o la diabetes no
controlada el médico puede utilizar el
ultrasonido y un monitor cardíaco fetal
que le ayudarán a decidir si el bebé
nacerá o no por cesárea cuando sea
necesario realizar un parto por cesárea
se le preparará para una cirugía si aún
no se le ha colocado se le colocará una
vía intravenosa y se le insertará un
catéter en la vejiga para drenar la
orina
en la sala de operaciones se le
anestesiar a en la mayoría de los casos
se administra una anestesia espinal para
adormecer la parte inferior del cuerpo
sin embargo algunas veces se utilizará
anestesia general
el médico comenzará realizando una
incisión en el abdomen será una incisión
vertical justo debajo del ombligo hasta
la parte superior del hueso púbico o con
mayor frecuencia una incisión horizontal
en forma transversal y justo por encima
del hueso púbico a esta insistió en
general se le denomina incisión de
bikini luego el médico realizará una
segunda incisión en la parte inferior
del útero una vez que se abre el útero
su médico romperá la bolsa amniótica si
aún está intacta y el bebé nacerá el
tiempo que transcurre desde la incisión
abdominal inicial hasta el nacimiento es
por lo general de cinco minutos
luego el médico pensará y cortará el
cordón umbilical
extraerá cuidadosamente la placenta y
suturar a bien el útero y abdomen
generalmente esto dura alrededor de 45
minutos por lo general la estadía en el
hospital después de un parto por cesárea
es de 3 a 5 días durante este tiempo se
le recomendará que am amante duerma
cuando el bebé duerme y se levanta de la
cama a menudo aunque la mayoría de las
pacientes pueden ocuparse de su bebé
recién nacido después del procedimiento
la recuperación completa puede tardar
entre 6 y 8 semanas la cicatriz se irá
aclarando a medida que sane